okay oh so this is the family portrait
from CSS Kampf us just a few months ago
it's so exciting to be here I can I can
hardly believe that it's actually
happened in May we had the first-ever
CSS comp in Amelia Island Florida paired
with Jay s Kampf us just like this is
paired with well you guys have so many
events here right now I don't know which
one is paired with but particularly I
guess joyous coffee you and it's just
really cool with a ton of help from
other people I organized the CSS conf in
the US and so just having this happen at
all is kind of amazing
one thing Christina asked me when we
were talking about this early on was why
did I do it and I said basically that
I'd been to lots of conferences
JavaScript conferences where everybody
was really nice to me and I had a really
good time but they thought I was a
designer and then I went a lot to a lot
of design conferences where again
everybody was really nice to me but they
thought I was a giant nerd and I was
like wait a minute CSS keeps falling
through the cracks right it's sort of
getting lost in the space between design
and development and maybe it needs its
own conference that can have enough love
I found myself wanting to meet other CSS
developers face to face I wanted to
basically look at people who loved see
it well let's be honest loved and hated
CSS just as much as I did right and and
so the way to do that was to create a
conference and that's the way that CSS
conf was originally born and very
luckily indeed right there you can see
I've circled it in red christina was in
the audience that day and she came back
to Berlin and together with Michael they
decided that CSS conf needed to come
here too there needed to be a Berlin
version and a Europe version of CSS conf
so I'd love to start off actually before
we even begin the day by giving them a
round of applause
they've worked so hard to get this day
to happen and to tie up all the details
and to make the breakfast as yummy as it
was and to get the parties to be fun and
to coordinate with the other events so
that we could meet people from the
different things that are happening
across Berlin so I want to talk to you a
little bit about how the talks were
chosen today I know that they they've
mentioned it a little bit there was a
blog post but I know that I missed the
blog post so I wanted to share that with
you the CSS community has sort of an
excellent history of curation but CSS
conf and for CSS Kampf Michael and
Christina really wanted to balance that
with community and so that's why they
had a call for speakers and that's why
the first level of speaker selection was
completely blind they had no idea who
the proposals were from no identifying
details they were choosing a hundred
percent based on how great the proposal
sounded and how much they wanted to see
those people speak here today and the
thing that that means is that next year
well you know while this year you're
attending next year it could be you
standing up here giving one of the talks
about some cool new project that you've
been doing throughout the year also be
thinking about that be keeping that in
your mind today like what are you doing
that someone would really love to hear
about they had an incredible amount of
proposals and I hope that they get even
more next year so I have to say as well
I love the lineup that they've chosen
looking through it the speakers are
doing some amazing work they are
challenging preconceived ideas and
pushing the boundaries of what's even
possible with CSS
sometimes they're breaking stuff in
order to learn and see how it can grow
I've been really looking forward to
hearing Peter talk about web components
and shooby talk about how Google is
handling their module system I'm pretty
sure that mike is going to completely
blow us away with his talk about
security vectors and CSS itself I know
just a tiny bit about that and I seems
almost impossible so I'm really excited
to see how that's gonna make me learn
something haven't thought about before
and for Anna's Maria's talk I'm just
hoping to keep up if I can even
understand what she's talking about I
think that'll be fantastic so I think
that you're gonna like their topics just
as much as the organizers do
and really curious to get into the day
and see how that goes so to ask you a
quick question why are you here and
answer it really quickly was I have no
idea while you're here I have no idea
whatsoever in fact I don't think you
know why you're here either even if you
think you do so when I come to a
conference sometimes I have a
preconceived notion about what's gonna
be you know the thing that matters and
I'm almost never right about it you know
I'll look at the schedule and I'll be
like I'm gonna go to that talk and this
talk and then you know especially if
it's multi-track trying to figure out
where I'm going to spend my time and
what's gonna be interesting and I'm
almost always wrong about what turns out
to be important in a conference so it's
sort of unexpected and wonderful to
arrive at a conference and to see what
turns out to be cool what happens when a
group of like-minded developers actually
get together and see what they can
create together so some of your reasons
why you thought you might be coming here
maybe your boss did some people did your
bosses send you anybody
nobody's willing to admit it oh we have
one nicely done yeah so maybe your boss
wanted you to come and learn new skills
and then bring that back to the company
that's a possible idea why you thought
you were coming
or maybe you brought yourself here
because your boss is just a little
disinterested in your new skills and you
think that's not such a good idea that
could be the case as well
but you know I think it's a little more
complicated than that I actually think
the stuff that can turn out to be
important can be a simple hallway
conversation where you thought it wasn't
anything at all when you were having it
and then it turns out that the person
completely inspired you to do something
you weren't thinking about before maybe
you'll meet someone will help you get
your next job you know that's possible
too you might not even be thinking
you're looking for a job and yet it
happens you might also meet someone
today who becomes a friend and so next
month when you're trying to solve a
really hard technical problem there's
some bug that you just can't figure out
that person now you know them you've met
them face to face so you can say hey you
know I'm really screwing up here it's
been a day and a half that I've been
trying to debug this thing can you jump
in and take a peek at it and help me
figure out what's going on so those are
all kinds of reasons maybe it'll be one
of the talks you know maybe one of the
talks will capture your interest may
you've never thought about security but
after hearing that talk you'll go oh wow
I'm really curious about that and start
to get into it and start to delve in and
learn more maybe you need to be
reanalyzed maybe you've gotten bored at
work or bored in what you're doing and
that could happen today as well
the biggest thing I think is to find
your community and that's that's why CSS
Kampf was created and that's what I hope
for you here today so one thing that I'm
hoping for here is that of balancing the
time spent as a student and as a teacher
I noticed it in my work I was often
having to be the CSS expert you know
everybody and the company would come to
me and say how does this work why isn't
it working what's going on here and I
always had to have the answers and so
conferences give you a chance to
actually switch roles for a bit and
maybe take a little bit more of the
student time and learn about things or
maybe you're always in the student role
at work and coming here you can share
your knowledge with somebody else that
you mean I think it's important to kind
of be in both places so the word career
is kind of a weird word to me it rose in
popularity at the end of the last
century it has its origins in French and
Latin words that are sort of vaguely
related to racetracks which honestly
kind of make me feel like a little
hamster running in the wheel I think the
trouble with focusing on your career and
coming with very exact objectives to a
conference is that rather than following
up on what really brings you joy you end
up sort of pursuing and running after a
sort of abstract notion of what success
is and it doesn't have the authenticity
of pursuing your real interests so I'm
going to go out on a limb and say to
hell with your career let's just follow
your heart I think it's almost
impossible in any given moment to figure
out how the things that you're doing day
to day fit into the big picture so I
think it's important to just follow your
gut and not worry too much about that do
stuff that interest you stop doing stuff
that doesn't interest you anymore talk
to people you enjoy and see what the
relationship brings and step out of your
comfort zone learn something you don't
know much about already oh there's a
cartoon in the u.s. called Family Circus
and when the little boy goes out to play
in the neighborhood this is how they
design that basically they get little
picture the neighborhood and the dotted
line shows how he's just moving in and
out around the neighborhood checking out
different things running in the
playground playing in his TP doing all
this stuff that he's doing this sort of
interests me because I read a research
paper that said that people who
considered themselves the luckiest in
the world and sorry I always forget the
origins of all the research papers I
read I tried to find it last night with
Google but did not have any luck so
people who considered themselves the
luckiest were those who added the most
variation to their day they took a
different route to work or followed up
on unexpected tangents went to a coffee
shop that they weren't expecting or
maybe attended a conference and met
people that they weren't thinking that
they would meet um so perhaps this
conference can be a chance for you to
allow room for a happy chance meeting or
a collaboration so this is slightly
self-indulgent so I hope you'll you'll
bear with me but I want to talk to you a
little bit about how my career has gone
in order to tell you so about some of
those like happy chance moments that can
happen so I got asked to speak at a
career event for college students in
Australia and my response was are you
sure I don't think you have the person
that you think you do so these students
were all wanting to be web developers
and I was supposed to come there and
tell them what the path was to becoming
a web developer and I think as any of us
knows they're sort of an infinite number
of paths to becoming a web developer but
I think mine is particularly not
recommended in a bunch of cases so my
high school was terrible like really
really terrible it was really tiny I
graduated from high school not knowing
even vaguely when the two world wars
were and I was seventh in my class so it
wasn't like I wasn't studying we just
never actually studied 20th century
history at all we didn't do any grammar
except for maybe six months when I was
17 it was a pretty terrible school so
when I got to college the course
catalogue for me was like this I don't
know it was like Christmas over and over
and over again every every few months a
new course catalog would come out
and I would read it like oh my god what
am I gonna study and I took all these
courses that didn't you know I did
you're supposed to think about a major
and what you're what you're trying to
achieve with it but I didn't i just took
chemistry and biology and sculpture and
drawing and actually no computer science
at that point I took I took whatever I
felt like philosophy or or art or
anything and never really quite knew
what it was gonna do and at one point my
dad sat me down and he's like Nicole you
do realize that the reason people go to
college is to graduate and you need to
get a degree in something at some point
and so I went through all of the
different majors that my university had
and I did some math and I figured out
which one I was closest to having a
degree in and then I finished off a
degree in that and so I ended up being
an economics major of all things but
that just happened to be the thing that
was mathematically closest to the
classes that I had already taken yeah so
you can imagine I'm speaking to this
group of students in Australia and the
teachers eyes are getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and it doesn't get
better either so when I graduated it
turns out the degrees you can get I was
sorry the jobs you can get with an
undergraduate degree in economics are
truly terrible I wrote credit reports
for a few months before it started
stealing my soul and I had to run away
at that point I decided that I would
become a carpenter and then I would
build houses for a living and so I
called up all the places in the
newspaper advertising jobs and they were
like no no no finally one guy said come
in if we don't hate you after a week
maybe we won't fire you okay that's
awesome I was like great I'll be there
no problem and I started off on the low
end of the totem pole like you know my
job would be that giant heap of lumber
over there that's been used already take
the nails out of all of it and then move
it over there and that was like months
and months of my life before I got
gradually allowed to do more and more
interesting things um so how did I
become a web developer from carpentry
and economics you can imagine these
students are just like yeah
think I'm gonna follow that path I hurt
my hands doing carpentry and I was
really scared because at this point I
had three years invested in a carpentry
career I wasn't really thinking of it
that way but I did have three years
invested in learning and getting better
at this thing and my doctor said to me
you have to stop you're going to be
disabled when you're older if you don't
stop doing this work I mean I was
lifting gigantic windows and I wasn't
bigger than I am now it just it really
wasn't a super good idea I guess
physically so I moved to France I was
skipping over a few steps there but it
seemed like a good idea at the time even
though I didn't speak French and I was
an illegal immigrant because I didn't
have a visa because they don't give
visas to laborers basically so I was in
France and I was super bored I'm like I
can't go to school I can't get a job you
can't do anything if you're an illegal
immigrant it's a super bad position to
be in so I started reading w3c specs to
pass the time yeah and at the time I
wasn't thinking like oh this is awesome
I'll get a job in this I was just like
Oh curious new thing like let me let me
see what this is all about
right and it was great like I found
actually the CSS spec that I had written
notes in the margin because I'd printed
that out because back then people
printed things out and I you know wrote
all kinds of notes in the margin and
stuff like that and it's really neat to
see my little brain working through like
how does this stuff work
to be fair I read XML schema first and
so that made me really really terrified
but yeah so I continued with that and
did bigger and bigger projects and got
into the performance side of things and
really started to enjoy it and then I
had gotten a job at Yahoo and I got laid
off and that can be a huge thing right
you think oh no like I got granted it
was in the period where Yahoo was laying
off pretty much everyone but it's scary
you're like okay what am I gonna do now
what's what is the next thing is this
thing that I thought I was invested in
just went away from one day to the next
um so I started a company because I'd
been doing performance and UI
you eye development and help internally
at Yahoo so I thought you know this
could be a thing that someone does
externally as well later on I decided to
become a speaker kind of accidentally as
well it turns out when I was a carpenter
I had played dance dance revelution with
John Alsop who does the you know this is
ridiculous
in Japan played Dance Dance Revolution
with John Alsop who runs web directions
north and south and all the web
directions and that was not but I mean
it was long before I was doing any nerdy
stuff at all and then years later he's
like want to come speak at my conference
and I was like yes
sure I have not really done that kind of
thing but let's you know let's
absolutely do it and he's the kind of
guy who will take a risk on a speaker
who's never spoken anywhere before much
like you know Christina and Michael will
do when they get a really good proposal
does it doesn't care wants to you know
go for it and see what can come of it so
that's how I became a speaker and then I
told you about the conference organizing
I basically wanted to meet you guys and
so I thought okay well I'm gonna throw a
really big pain in the ass party and
it's gonna have speakers and be really
fun and so sometimes the stuff that you
do it just it's so hard to see there are
these moments like I didn't think when I
was playing Dance Dance Revolution in
Japan like years before I ever thought
about web development but that would be
how I'd get my first speaking gig but it
was fun and so I jumped in and I did it
and it's often those things that you do
without knowing how they add up to some
big end goal that end up being really
really cool um so two months ago I had
another one of those moments around a
really silly romantic comedy which I'm a
little bit embarrassed to admit but it's
called he's just not that into you and
the premise is that there's this girl
who is having some trouble dating she's
like going out with these guys but
they're not calling her back or they're
taking two weeks to call her back and
she's going what am I doing wrong should
I call them should I say this what if I
said that instead and then finally one
of her friends just says he's just not
that into you he just doesn't like you
that much
there's nothing you can do about it and
the interesting thing was I watched it
and I thought oh my god that's how I
feel about owning my own company right
now I'm just not that into it I don't
want to call it back I don't want to go
out on another date I'm just sort of
like yeah all right
so I have a company and so I quit and
sort of quit I'm getting quitting over
time but the truth be told right now I
have no idea how that fits into the
bigger picture I don't know what I'm
gonna do next I don't know why I am
right here right now but I do know that
since I did that I've been more excited
and I've been having more fun than I had
had in ages I wrote three blog posts in
one day after not writing any for like
nine months or a year it completely
changed my perspective letting go of
this thing that I thought was my career
and I needed to hang on to it I'm
learning Ruby and JavaScript to
complement my CSS because I want to be
able to build more cooler things and not
have to ask somebody else to build the
other part of it for me so why did I do
this I have no idea at all except that I
know now that I'm moving toward the
thing that feels like the right thing to
do and I'm gonna go for it
and I hope that the reasons will make
sense long-term there's these moments
where I go oh dear God it's not gonna
make sense but I believe that all those
other times I followed my heart you know
I played Dance Dance Revolution in Japan
and it worked out so those critical
life-changing moments you rarely know
that they're important or critical when
they're actually happening so I think we
have to jump in and like get involved in
an open-source project or attend a
conference that we weren't going to
attend or participate more fully in the
community so that we have back up when
we can't figure out that nasty bug so
you know maybe you never have thought
you were interested in animation until
you hear Rachel stock or you know maybe
Chris and Alex's talks will make you
want to get involved in pre-processors
and digging into the guts of how they
work and making them better
maybe roz fun and Angelina will inspire
you to look to the future of
technologies that you live and breathe
every day and to
see around that corner at what is gonna
be next or maybe Harry will help you
push back on the design that you're
getting and get better styles from your
designer so that you can build something
that you really believe in and that
you're happy with so I suggest that
today you go out and you discover the
secret of why you're here the thing that
you couldn't have planned for in advance
because who knew you know you had to get
all these cool people in a room and you
had to see what happened to find out
exactly what it was about thank you
you